tenir ma ligne mais d'un point de vue
amical d'un professionnel est absolument
pas physique pour les 9 ans je voulais
une invitée vraiment que j'aime plus que
tout et aujourd'hui j'ai pas peur de le
dire et je ne veux dire à personne douce
emma dos c'est ma came présentatrice non
pas du tout préférez je le dis dans tout
le monde sait elle que je préfère ça y
est j'ai plus ma liste
aussi je vous aime voilà a été relancé
tous les deux on le sait tous les deux
je dirais moi on est dans une amitié
mais pas on n'en friends aux frères ya
rien et on est plus qu on prenne
d'autres à moi j'ai des gènes miron se
crée effectivement quelqu'un j'ai comme
tout le monde je me décide ce plateau il
est passé de simple est notre bouche et
pourtant les admire malick mais d'un
point de vue amical non professionnel
est absolument pas physique mais on doit
déjà vu
admirateur secret il ya un invité
mystère ce soir puisqu'on est une
surprise pour vous derrière le rideau il
ya une personne que vous connaissez
avec qui vous avez travaillé il ya
quelques années sur la chaîne comédie
rappelle toi nous voir
c'est rapahël de michael ou pas ben
ouais michel che tu ça fait combien de
temps que tu as pas revu ça fait
longtemps
enfin on voit ça fait 20 ans ah oui
j'aime beaucoup nikos c'est votre
vraiment c'est un animateur que vous
aimez bien je trouve assez polyvalent il
est fort il sait faire plein de choses
il est agréable c'est vrai mais je vous
préfère vous je les adore elles sont un
truc à dire à julia à l'est pas déjà que
je la suis depuis des années enfin voilà
le shanxi a fait tu vas démons
admirateur secret dur et je regarde hors
jeu ce soir c'est sûr ça c'est obligé
quand je la vois j'ai les larmes aux
yeux la même trempe
et là franchement chez michael oui oui
un poisson d'avril
non non largement bras c'est vrai oui
merci
en fait je voulais te demandé de
m'épouser
[Rires]
non mais la fatigue le retour finissant
médicale sans rigoler ici non c'est pas
demain que c'est sincère qui transpire
si michael alors il faut que je te dise
quelque chose je ne suis pas célibataire
et j'ai pris un mauvais prix qui
s'appelle la fidélité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
julia vignali est ce qu'on peut me
redonner la date d'aujourd'hui la date
de notre rencontre avec une dent
aujourd'hui la date du 1er avril bob de
suite un poisson d'avril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]